[Music]
foreign
welcome to the reason Roundtable your
weekly podcast from the magazine that
loves Freedom every bit as much as
Flacco the Eurasian eagle owl
I am Matt Welch joined by Nicholas B
Peter souderman and Catherine mangyu
Ward hi everyone howdy I believe it's
pronounced Flacco Iowa Flacco I mean
Flaco would also be kind of cool if it
was named after uh you know former uh
Arizona senator of uh Jeff happy
whatever the heck that was
you should you there should be a Jeff
Flake look-alike Eurasian eagle owl
prowling the Mean Streets of Central
Park I think we can all agree on that at
the outset of this podcast okay
um sorry Start strong uh yeah I think
maybe I think we're done here was how we
can't even uh stretch our arms out on
the porch in the morning without
inadvertently punching some politician
who wants to crack down on Tick Tock
right in the face on Fox News this
Sunday it was Senate intelligence
committee chairman Mark Warner how long
has he been there Nick is it wasn't Mark
working well he's one of the original
Warner Brothers right he's one of the
original Warner Brothers so I you know
120 years something like that uh he
announced a broad bipartisan Bill BBB B
Cubed to give the federal government
leeway to ban Chinese technology
including the popular video sharing
service you have 100 million Americans
on Tick Tock for 90 minutes every day
the Virginia Democrats said they are
taking data from Americans not keeping
it safe but what worries me more with
Tick Tock is that this can be a
propaganda tool
if by Propaganda Mark Warner means
[__] 12 second dance lip syncing
routines then yes I have witnessed this
evil in my own house the house uh
foreign affairs committee last week
fast-tracked similar bill that would
give the executive branch Authority
Under the international emergency
economic Powers Act that sounds great to
ban Tick-Tock if the administration
determines the company has knowingly
transferred user data to any foreign
person I should use for dater that's
fine take care uh yeah it's like I hate
those people in Washington yeah
maybe we should write a book together
quite a bit right now uh anyways yeah if
you're under the influence uh if they
share the data data with uh any uh
person working for or under the
influence of the red Chinese government
then that could be banned that just
scratches the surface of proposed
governmental remedies including outright
legislative bans suggested by the likes
of surprise just Senator Josh Hawley
Tick Tock is prohibited already on
government work phones in about half the
country plus many State University
networks Democratic senator Michael
Bennett is pushing Apple and Google to
just remove tick tock from their app
stores that'll work uh but it's not just
concern about commies there's widespread
societal and social scientific anxiety
popularized by the likes of Jonathan
height no stranger to your earlobes that
the sharp uptick in teen mental health
issues over the past decade or so
particularly among the girls is
attributable to smartphones and social
networks
handing Tick Tock to a teenage girl the
feeling goes is like asking them to play
Russian Roulette or do I mean red
Chinese roulette Catherine no
um Bravo yeah all right let's just give
me a little extra time to prepare in the
morning it's terrible uh Catherine uh I
want to get into the uh teen anxiety
stuff a little bit later but I think
that you might have burst a blood vessel
this morning
um uh reading some of the quotes from
various politicians about this do you
want to share the crazy did you spill
your coffee on your editor trousers do
that in fact I was in kind of the
opposite situation
um for those who are close listeners to
this podcast you will recall that I
busted up my knee so as a result I've
been writing a [__] exercise bike
every morning like a douchebag wow and
so I was on the bike just pedaling away
full of resentment and when I cracked
open this wired article about a
potential Tic Tac band and it is a good
article full of bad things it is just
Banger after Bank just terrible terrible
quotes from idiots nicely arranged for
my information and this one was the one
that broke me it was somewhere around
mile four
can we just admit that the Chinese
Communist Party
is an adversary and Silicon Valley is
not an actual adversary it says Senator
Kevin Kramer of North Dakota a
republican these are similar issues but
they're not the exact same issues the
Chinese Communist party is an adversary
Silicon Valley is an unruly child
screw Okay Kevin Kramer of North Dakota
sounds like an AI General like a real
Senator I agree figure right like did
anybody check that it is uh Kevin Kramer
I mean the very notion first of all that
we would talk about the PowerHouse of
like Innovation and cool stuff in this
country as unruly children the fact that
we talk about any American that a
senator would talk about any American
citizens as unruly children is just
absolutely shocking and then you know
you're surprised by that that seems like
the least surprising thing I can imagine
about a a sitting elected official with
a lot of power over people's lives
I know they believe that but it's really
a kind of say the quiet part loud
scenario to me I don't know
um but yeah so as you say there's kind
of these dual justifications for why we
gotta make the tick tock go away forever
and one is the teen girls are sad and
we'll talk about that more and then the
other is China
um the China thing
is largely hypothetical which I think is
interesting like all of the discussions
of this are not
we have a Smoking Gun of the ways in
which the Chinese government is using
Tick Tock either to gather data about
Americans or to like psyop mood
manipulate our teens with the videos
which is absolutely a serious thesis
that is being run uh around on Capitol
Hill right now you can't ban a product
that millions of people use on a
hypothetical especially because
this narrow band won't even solve the
problem there is there's still plenty of
opportunities for American companies to
sell share share conclusions from data
of the same type with other nations
including China and we shouldn't ban
that either or or for China to just do
it on the road like they don't need a
dedicated feed going directly into you
know Chinese government right computers
it's like all of this stuff is available
on every social if you do have National
Security concerns there are also that
that were serious and well substantiated
there would still be many ways to
minimize those risks without just flatly
Banning a product that millions of
people use and love you know the uh
essential read on this the the
pre-buttal to the current Mania is the
uh recent reason article co-authored by
Milton Mueller uh who's been writing for
internet Freedom going back to the early
80s that reason but
um he's got a great piece recently and
reason uh with a co-author whose name is
escaping me and I apologize for that but
runs through all of the arguments why
this is a classic internet hysteria
um and should not be taken seriously and
that the main policy prescription which
is okay let's ban it so China is bad
partly because of the great firewall of
China which we've been hearing about for
decades now where they ban free access
to their citizens on internet stuff
we're gonna fix them by doing something
amazingly similar
it's like great you know why don't we
why don't you know once Russia starts
drafting people why don't we start
instituting a draft uh maybe you know
you got to Fight Fire with Fire the
co-author is by the way uh Georgia
Tech's Kareem Farhat
thank you uh Nick that sounded
dangerously close to a Washington Post
editorial at least a pitch there oh yeah
yeah I I have uh uh ironic quotes about
it all but no it's it's it's amazing how
like all you have to do to resurrect the
shittiest arguments of the Cold War is
sprinkle you know some kind of like
internet fairy dust on it or something
like that or social media now the
internet is too old
um but
um you know once once we're talking
about social media uh the my favorite uh
argument that is starting to emanate
from this with the stink of you know
like week old socks on top of a laundry
hamper is the idea that you know in
China Tick Tock exclusively is used to
teach like you know uh you know eighth
year calculus to uh you know uh uh
babies in utero in China but here all
we're doing is milk crate challenges and
silly dances so the real threat to this
is that it's distracting children from
learning how level math so we can
compete with China I should mention how
my teen now uh teen girl is 14 has
evolved in her Tick Tock usage used to
be the aforementioned uh [__] dancing
and lip singing and there's probably
still some of that but mostly now she
and her cohort are using it to share
clips of culture that they enjoy
um and for her that is uh two main
sources these days uh which probably
tells you something about my parenting
if nothing else uh one is uh uh videos
from Breaking Bad or like compilation
videos from Breaking Bad and the other
is South Park she's absolutely
hysterically pro-south Park and just is
sending me Tick Tock clips of editing
South Park day after day Peter uh I want
you to react to your fellow Floridian uh
Senator Marco Rubio said the following
about Tick Tock it's kind of a long
quote but just bear with me here if
you're certainly imagine him dancing to
it doing a tick tock dance oh my God
yeah
action would be like better than Michael
stipend he has to stand on a table yeah
he has to stand on a table so we can see
his whole body but that's me and the
quote if you're certainly willing to fly
a balloon over your Continental airspace
and have people see it with a naked eye
what would make you not weaponize data
to have virtually all of the data on
over 50 million American devices
accessed daily by the Communist Party of
China will pose an Indescribable risk to
America's national security to our
economy to our competitiveness just
think about the advantage China would
have uh information on us their
government would have information on us
that no government in the history of the
world has ever had on the citizens of
another country there's nothing to
compare it to uh Peter is he right or
just totally right I think a lot of this
is really hyperbolic at the same time
I'm not sure I totally agree with
Catherine that the concerns about
Chinese government use of data and
interaction with American Media
companies and sort of American
entertainment is totally hypothetical
because we in fact do know how China
interacts with American media and
entertainment companies
um because there are there there are a
lot of American companies that do
business with China the NBA and video
game companies in Hollywood in
particular in what China ends up doing
is it prohibits criticism of an an
authoritarian regime even light indirect
and implied criticism it makes it makes
American corporations toe the line it
makes American movie stars issue
completely ridiculous apologies for
having accidentally said like the wrong
three-word phrase in the midst of an
answer um right and implicitly it
doesn't make that's true you're right it
doesn't make sense it's simply it simply
it creates a domestic enemy right it's
implicit but what it does is it creates
an environment where if they want to do
business in China they feel like they
have to do this right and so American
movie companies are editing movies uh
for the Chinese market right they
sometimes get totally different scenes
um uh villains are removed because of
the Chinese market right because uh in
in order not to offend uh China and in
some ways this is small ball stuff and
this is I think is actually sort of
where I'm like less concerned about this
is even is like in some ways like this
is objectionable and I don't like it and
in other ways I guess I'm not that I
don't feel like it's a giant national
security threat that I don't know a a
former wrestler who's now a movie star
has to issue an awkward apology for some
of this stuff I'm not like that bothered
by all of this personally I don't feel
like it's that big a deal at the same
time I don't think it's nothing and I
think that like as Libertarians who are
concerned about government power we
should be concerned about the biggest
most oppressive totalitarian regime on
the planet and the ways that they
exercise power not only over their own
citizens but the ways that they will
sort of use soft power to uh to to do
you don't know what and this is right do
what again and this is and this is and
this is
I agree with you this is the biggest
flaw in this argument is everyone's like
well China will have a lot of data and
they will do
and then it's like they'll that's it
there's a big Blake after that and it's
not obvious what they're gonna do with
all of our Tick Tock videos except
suppress the ones that are like let me
tell you why China is a very bad
authoritarian totalitarian government
and in some ways that's bad but you know
what there's always Facebook there's
always Twitter and there's always you
know uh there's always sub stack if you
want to like share your anti-china uh
like China is very bad just you know
destroying like the the the like the
freedom for you know a billion people uh
arguments and like yeah are we that
worse off because you can't say that on
Tick Tock and Tick Tock is very popular
I don't know I I in some ways I also
just don't people don't care because
five or ten years from now no one will
be on Tick Tock no that's not true
that's that's what that is also hyper
hyperbole at the same time I just I've
used social media as like not a static
Arrangement and the fact that Tick Tock
is the uh the social media site of the
moment and the one that teams are
currently obsessed with like the thing
that we know from the last 20 years of
social media is that 10 years from now
Tick Tock will no longer be the hot cool
thing and to try to and to treat it as
this giant threat even if you think
there are legitimate concerns with like
Chinese Communists authoritarian
governments you know who like in fact do
demand a certain amount of um a certain
amount of uh sort of control from
chinese-owned companies right like
Chinese owned companies operate
genuinely differently than American
companies do with regards to the ways
that they they interact with their
government at the same time it's like 10
years from now 10 years from now
everybody's going to be in the metaverse
you're arguing now with yourself people
argue with you uh besides yourself I
mean if if I may uh just one one really
important factor to this specific debate
is that the versions of tick tock that
are available outside of China do not
censor as far as far as you know is
known do not censor content and this is
part of the Mueller article uh where he
really talks about how you know
criticism of the Chinese government uh
and you know uh defenses have fallen
gong and and other things that are
verboten to talk about in China is
available there Peter I agree that there
is something really disturbing about the
way the U.S entertainment industry is
kowtowing to China in all sorts of
obvious ways and less obvious ways and
that should be a absolute uh you know
topic of conversation station but again
that's not what we're talking about here
what we're talking about is a biparticle
bipartisan consensus brewing in the U.S
of the government they're not going to
restrict China you know they're going to
restrict Americans ability to do what
they want to say what they want and it
has to be called out as a you know a
kind of Internet fueled social media
enabled hysteria that should stop and we
should be having those arguments I mean
it's you know it's still about uh the uh
the U.S entertainment industry the way
the NBA responded uh to mild criticisms
of China the way that Blizzard
Entertainment and other uh you know
other actors have done we should be
having a robust screaming match about
that in America uh because that's [__]
up and that's something we can control
as consumers or we can affect as
consumers uh Catherine let's go to the
John height argument about this our Tick
Tock social media apps smartphones the
whole lot like hand finding a loaded gun
to adolescent girls and if so have you
already handed that gun to yours because
guns are awesome uh guns are awesome and
I'm looking forward to my newly 12 year
old daughter going to uh learning to
shoot rifles camp this summer uh which
is which is it's three weeks it's three
weeks in the woods that's the Lyle and
Eric Menendez it's like a it's like a
1920s like uh 1920s feminism Camp so
it's like all girls but it's like we
gals gotta dress for dinner and learn to
shoot guns it's gonna be great anyway
um that's what I have given her I have
not yet given her Tick Tock because I
think that a big part of this equation
I'm old enough to remember when
Libertarians and conservatives would say
stuff about parental responsibility I
don't know what happened to that that's
fully gone well we still have parental
responsibility it's just that the
Senators think that Americans are the
chill children and they're the parents
right they're the quality children
that's a good point that's an excellent
point parental responsibility is now
solely in the hands of a made-up senator
from a Dakota but
um the
you know I do think that's West Dakota
do you think that's a a huge part of
this equation is like my kid's not on
Tick Tock yet she will be because it's
pretty fun I love Tic Tac I spend I am
part of the Americans that spend many
many minutes a day on Tick Tock
um it's delightful uh I am annoyed at
Tic Tac for promoting uh for the kind of
censorship it actually does do which is
um you know obscenity and kind of um you
know that that type of content because
it means that all the people use dumb
euphemisms for everything they're still
talking about these topics but they just
use like um only pans is like what they
say instead of only fans and it's like I
don't think that's working I think this
has just made everyone sound stupid so
I'm I there is some censorship
but as far as we can tell in American
Tick Tock as uh as noted it is not
it is not in the service of the the red
Chinese
um so wait so it's like The Big Lebowski
when you watch it on television and and
John Goodman is yelling this is what
happens when you find a stranger in the
Alps except that's not what he's saying
exactly that people edit their captions
so they still verbally say the words but
the captions don't have it on the theory
that maybe the algorithm is searching
the captions it's dumb anyway this does
not answer your question your question
is what about the sad teen girls there's
clearly something real going on and I am
sympathetic to what seems to be a large
cohort of like men in their 50s who are
really really worried about this
um I am be nice
yeah they're called about it too
Catherine but I think it is you know my
bias here is that it is almost always a
mistake to select for a mono causal
technological explanation for a social
phenomenon
that's it well that's well put this is
that right now that's where the distance
uh can I just point out uh and I realize
this has nothing to do with what we're
talking about but when you were talking
about censorship on tickets
you know
well what you know Google the filthiest
sex acts you can imagine no on Twitter
on Twitter and there is there is
hardcore pornography available on
Twitter and all of the discussions of
Twitter and censorship and content
moderation like I've never heard anybody
just point out you know there is
hardcore porn there's a lot of hardcore
porn on the Internet like there's plenty
no no no but what not not on not on
Facebook not on uh uh Instagram not on
Twitter you you would expect not on
Twitter but it's there and it's how do
you define hardcore
versus other types uh Google hardcore
porn Peter Google Imagine something and
enter it into Twitter and you will uh
you'll get it no lemon maybe uh all
right uh last week what is that uh did
you just make that on Peter suderman
please
don't
just just please Matt Welch was he kind
of hosted the original
remembering correct don't don't do it if
you do it while we're doing this this uh
podcast it's gonna be bad this listener
and participant alike uh let's pivot to
Peter suderman uh not about lemon
parties yet but about the Great Piece he
wrote last week that I want to talk
about the headline in subhead are as
follows Decades of subsidies have made
the essentials of middle class life
increasingly difficult to afford the
basics of middle class life are too
expensive but more subsidies won't help
Peter please explain to the class how
government interventions to make things
affordable have made things more
expensive paradoxical so there's been
this fascinating political movement over
the the past couple of years where they
where like it's mostly been on the
center left and it has come I think in
in large part as a reaction to the kind
of the conflagrations and the
distractions of the Trump era right like
since 2015 my American politics has had
a lot going on and it's been kind of
crazy some of it's been serious some of
it's been very silly but something has
gotten lost in in our political
discourse and that has been what we used
to call kitchen table issues which is
like basic cost of living issues and
those have come back to the fore in part
because people are just experiencing
them generally and in part because of
inflation and in part because uh some of
the the essentials of middle class life
or at least what people feel like are
the essentials of middle class life
people have started to realize in a
particular center-left pundits have
started to realize oh my God they're
really really expensive and the three
things that I focus on in this post are
Healthcare education particularly higher
education and housing and so we have
this movement now on the center left
called the that that is sort of loosely
uh coalescing around the term the
abundance agenda and their argument is
well you know we've we've uh it's like
it's focused I think more on housing
than on anything else and they have like
a a totally non-insane argument which is
one reason that housing is so expensive
is we've made it really hard to build
things and what we need to do is to let
Builders build things that will put more
Supply on the market and that will help
us ease prices at the same time health
care and higher education have kind of
been talked about within this this
constellation of issues of things that
are really really expensive but there's
been a lot less attention I think paid
to the fact that those two uh that those
two sectors of the economy have for the
last 40 or 50 years just been incredibly
subsidized starting in the 1960s 1970s
1980s we have just pumped billions and
billions tens hundreds trillions of
dollars uh into into subsidies for these
things and what has that done well in
higher education it's really very clear
what uh what collect trillions of
dollars worth or over a trillion dollars
worth of of loans has done it's made it
in some ways uh it's it's provided money
for people to to pay for college tuition
but then the universities are just like
well that also makes it easy for us to
spend more money on administrators and
swimming pools and also just to jack up
tuition because we can because we know
that you have the money because buyers
have more money because they are being
given it through subsidies that makes it
more expensive inherently and so then
you have uh then you have this
um this sort of trajectory where costs
go up and subsidies go up in Tandem and
and the underlying thing is actually
becoming much more expensive and the
same thing is true in healthcare I mean
the United States government in some
ways can be thought of as a kind of a
health insurance company that also does
defense and some other stuff and like we
spend so much money so much public money
on health care every single year and
people like why does health care cost so
much it's really really expensive Maybe
be maybe what we need to do is add some
more subsidies to make it less expensive
and all that does is at best it
temporarily Shields people from prices
right like it it can make those prices
invisible to people but making prices
invisible to people means that the
market is no longer responsible or
responsive to price signals and that
drives prices up that drives costs up
and then we end up in a situation where
we are now which is hey everything that
is important
Education Health Care housing is really
really expensive huh I wonder why that
is and it's it's at least in part
because we've spent the last four or
five or six decades subsidizing the hell
out of all of those things and I think
that there has that the abundance agenda
Center left has not spent enough time
recognizing
um Reckoning with with the effects of
those subsidies and certainly Democratic
politicians who seem very very keen even
if they're sort of Center Lefty types
very very keen to keep those subsidies
flowing and keep expanding them
certainly the the Democratic political
class has not reckoned with that at all
Catherine what's your favorite example
of uh subsidies to make things more
affordable not doing that it's just
education it's just higher education I
mean that's it's not a like a
cute little surprise answer but it is
the most important one I think because I
don't care about buying a house but I
really care about you know education
um this weekend my my guy venture
capitalist Mark Andreessen and recent
recent uh reason interview victim uh
spoke at a conference and he said we are
headed into a world where a flat screen
TV that covers your entire wall costs a
hundred dollars and a four-year degree
costs a million dollars and that's right
that's right and he said this you know
he said this over and over he has this
whole thing about like fast and slow
parts of the economy which map neatly
onto the regulated and the unregulated
but also in our interview which you can
listen to on the reason interview
podcast with Nicole Espy you know one
thing that we talked about is that this
the place where you are allowed to
innovate
is when it doesn't matter so when it's
something frivolous you can try
something bold and new and awesome but
if things are really important we can't
let the market take care of it that's
kind of like the place that we are and
it's the worst possible place to be like
this is why Silicon Valley is unruly
children it's because we we have only
given them the frivolous to act on
and it's it's like just very very
frustrating because the more important
something is the more Innovation you
want in that space and we've created
exactly opposite incentives with these
subsidies
but we've had huge innovation in the
viral dance routines yeah we have that
is true
uh Nick but also we're in the higher ed
Market what I was going to say is I I
generally I like the abundance uh agenda
stuff coming out of the left I've hung
out I should say that too just since I
probably no but you're criticizing them
there's no no no but in your
directionally correct in a lot of ways
in your piece you point out that you
know they are now you know they they
haven't fully accounted for or you know
to some degree they they understand that
if you subsidize demand without
increasing Supply you just you get
higher prices but you know and and the
the easy answer is to stop subsidizing
demand and allowing Supply to grow what
I was going to say though is that
they're I think that the market in
housing markets and housing Healthcare
and higher education in particular are
very distinct and they follow different
uh kind of imperatives and part of
what's going on in higher education is
not simply that a lot of money is being
pumped into the system if you break
things down first off more and more
people are second or third generation
going to college and they are demanding
a different type of product and this is
more of a class-based analysis than
anything if you went to a directional
State University you want your kid to go
to the flagship state school and then
those their kids want to go to a private
school even if it's not academically as
good as you know like a Big Ten
University uh there that is driving huge
increases in in higher education
spending if you look at State School
tuition and fees over the past decade
it's been flat uh totally within the
reach of almost anybody who qualifies as
middle class because of financial aid or
because your parents make enough that's
not what people are talking about and
you know tuition and fees at many places
has been flat or even declining because
it is sensitive to demand but the
consumers of higher education are saying
well I want the climbing wall I want the
Lazy River I want a different type of
experience and you have have to factor
in like each each of these major uh you
know kind of sub economies responds to
different things uh you know there's no
question that Medicare more than
anything else is the major engine of
price inflation but it's also true when
you go to the doctor you are getting a
radically different experience than you
know now than if you went in 1973 the
pharmacopia is much more robust the
machines the Diagnostics Etc and we need
to account for that because in each of
these industries something different is
helping to drive the prices up and
sometimes that's stupid consuming you
know from my perspective I think a lot
of people uh higher education which has
become ubiquitous uh you know about
two-thirds of graduating high school
seniors go on directly to some form of
higher ed it's become a consumption good
a luxury good and a status good and I
think if people were more educated
consumers uh you know to paraphrase size
Sims of the great off-brand shopping
place a lot of this inflation would be
uh would be undercut
um all right we're gonna get to our
listener email the week here in a moment
but first
self-reliance responsibility using your
head there's just a few of the values we
try to embrace here at the reason
Roundtable that's why it's so fitting
for us to tell you about the air Medcare
Network and how it can take a financial
worry right off your plate the air Med
Care Network is America's largest
emergency air ambulance membership
Network their providers operate
state-of-the-art helicopters and their
specially trained medical personnel
provide the highest level of
pre-hospital emergency medical care you
see even with a seemingly robust health
insurance policies such flights can be
fantastically expensive but when you're
a member of the air Medcare Network you
won't see a bill for your flight when
flown by a participating provider that's
the kind of financial safety net a
self-reliant person should think about
having
membership is amazingly affordable only
99 dollars per year just 79 for seniors
Nick and it covers your entire household
what you're like you like you don't have
a membership to AARP I got my card like
a little month ago yeah I was merely
suggesting I couldn't hear you back
because uh yeah it's funny listeners who
act right now can get up to an 80
Mastercard or Amazon gift card when they
join just visit airmedcarenetwork.com
forward slash reason use the off code
reason and start enjoying peace of mind
today do it today you'll be glad you're
dead all right reminder to send your
terse queries to Roundtable at
reason.com this one comes from Brenner
Roth wonderful name who writes in part
my question is related to journalism
quality as the managing structure of
news organizations and incentives have
changed I.E private Equity buying
newspapers subscription-based models
becoming more prevalent how has this
affected reporting in our country a
political affiliation of the writer has
become a bigger issue but beyond that do
mainstream writers just not care don't
want to or cannot do deeper analysis
because of competing priorities or maybe
reader attention spans have gotten even
shorter and they can get away with it
seems like more and more journalists are
only concerned with Twitter battles I
look at the analysis coming from major
news outlets and it regularly seems to
be only surface level or just taking
things they hear at face value Catherine
can you reflect on how if at all uh
structural changes in the news Biz have
changed coverage or if it's the the
audience or what yeah I think that um I
guess I'm just hyping interviews that I
have done for a reason in the past on
this podcast today because
um one thing that really changed my
thinking on this or crystallized my
thinking on this I guess was the
interview I did a while back with Jimmy
Wales who founded Wikipedia
um and who has a whole theory of the
internet that is based on
um basically whether it is an ad based
model or a subscription-based model and
how that subtly affects the type of
content that gets produced and the ways
that people experience content online
um one thing that's happened in recent
years is that we're moving back toward a
subscription-based model
um that there's you know the
sub-stackification the sort of
increasing willingness of people to pay
for the content they want in addition to
the kind of technological Warfare of
um paywalls finally getting good enough
that they actually keep people out of
the content that they shouldn't see and
let people in to get enough of a taste
um
plus the rise of lots of different types
of journalistic content including
podcasting
um you know along with newsletters and
other types not just let's put it all on
a website or in uh you know dead tree
Edition
um all of that is by way of saying when
you're trying to get eyeballs for your
ads it generates different types of
content and I think that a lot of the
weariness that people feel with the news
is a secondary product of that that
reader attention spans are not
necessarily shorter so much as the way
that you make money doesn't require
readers to have attention spans
um one thing that's great about reason
is because we are a non-profit we can
prioritize stuff besides just the raw
numbers of clicks and the raw numbers of
eyeballs and the raw numbers of AD
Revenue though all those things are
important to us so I think that rather
than try to explain
you know everything through the lens of
um
yeah I think people are people are
tempted to this private Equity
explanation for instance I think it's
much more about
um the ways that we as journalists adapt
ourselves to the broader commercial
model that we exist in
um and that the move towards
subscription-based models will actually
be a good thing
Nick how would you answer this question
uh I agree with uh Catherine that you
know the the what what is going on is a
return or a move towards more of a
subscription-based model and it's out of
the broadcasting era you know which was
a dominant mode uh you know where
advertisers subsidize the cost of
newspapers either you know each Edition
or a subscription but on TV and radio
you paid nothing and the price you know
the what you had to put up with was ads
what we're seeing now increasingly is a
return to subscriptions
um and it's the small newspapers and and
the chains that are being bought by
private Equity firms
um that are struggling with this because
do you really want to you know if you
want to read the Indianapolis Star or
something like that do you want to you
know pay a hundred dollar subscription
in order to read one article that comes
across your feed probably not the New
York Times uh following on the early and
ongoing success of the Wall Street
Journal has finally been able all to you
know turn itself into a giant newsletter
that is you know that is subscription
based one of the things about that and
this has nothing to do with kind of the
quality of Journalism or uh or even the
quantity but it does change it if you
are doing effectively ideological
service journalism for your subscribers
and this is true of Something Like You
on the fifth column Matt or the New York
Times or whatever like you start playing
to your paying customers I know I had an
interesting conversation with Andrew
Heaton who has you know a couple of
popular podcasts and things like that
has you know worked at uh worked at
reason and done a lot of stuff with
videos but he will talk about you know
he's got like a 3 000 core subscriber
base and when he does something that
they dislike they let him know and he's
he's not slavishly devoted to them but
it's like you know you respond to that
in a way uh that in an advertising model
model it's a little bit easier sometimes
to to Bear the heat of intense
disagreement from your paying fan base
um you know these are people with skin
in the game and I worry about that at a
place like the New York Times
um if it becomes too devoted to
servicing what it thinks its readers
wants it's going to become less
interesting for a broader population
which again in the long run doesn't
matter but it does because you can
either like it or not and this is a
glorious time for great bizarre
wonderful in-depth investigative
reporting as well as all kinds of
[__] but it definitely changes the
way it works
uh I think there's a audience capture uh
is a threat we saw this in the early
days of uh blogging which I uh
participated in or like the secondary
days the first were about tech blogs and
then after 9 11 there was a bunch of
current affairs independent style blogs
and War blogs thank you Catherine I'm
here for you editor pants
um uh and you saw that with a lot of
people they got captured to just
Fantastical degrees the I think the best
example is uh Charles Johnson of little
green footballs just to throw us all
back um we got warped into some pretty
interesting places and then pulled
himself back and kind of scrubbed his
archives and and whatnot but it's very
difficult and you see now is he a member
of the reality-based community or the
unreality base the last time I paid
attention to Charles who I know uh or I
knew uh back in the day was probably
about 10 years ago and he was a very uh
Pro Obama by then so I guess the whole
pancake or skirting you're skirting the
question here yeah is that reality or
unreality I would see exactly right
um but uh Peter Let's uh before I
blather on too much uh you're a you're a
sub stacker uh I mean I think the answer
is just that incentives matter
um and so I will focus on a different
um set of incentives than we have talked
about so far the old ad driven Market
had particular content incentives in
terms of the type of content uh that
newspapers in particular
Weekly News magazines uh were interested
in running and so we've had this debate
about objective journalism and both
sides of over the past 20 years in part
as the old ad driven model has collapsed
um right the the idea of objective
journalism and you know sort of oh we're
just gonna tell both sides of the story
right and be neutral about it has been
sneered at a lot recently and I think in
some cases uh some of the critiques are
totally spot on
um but that that business that that
wasn't just a Content model that was a
business model and it was in part a
product of the fact that advertisers
back in the the old days and let's say
pre-2000. the advertisers were the most
important Market I mean in in 1985 or
1995 even if you paid for a newspaper or
magazine the publication often made
little or any money off your
subscription occasionally even lost
money off your subscription the idea was
just to show
advertisers that you were invested
enough to pay for it and they made all
of their money basically off of
advertising right and so that Mensch and
it was a lot of money I'm going to
interject that was 25 profit margins
there was almost no sector that was as
profitable as Daily City Newspapers
between 1960 and and that was true in
small markets like Cleveland and
Cincinnati or medium-sized markets let's
say like mediums you know like Cleveland
and Cincinnati as well as New York and
Los Angeles it wasn't just you know uh
it wasn't just a couple of big National
papers which is the market we are
increasingly moving towards now right
and so they were responsive to
Advertiser concerns and advertisers
historically were somewhat antsy about
partisan political news and news that
appeared to be slanted right they all or
I won't say all but they by and large
took the Michael Jordan line you know
Republicans buy shoes too right it
didn't pay to be political in the way
that you went about selling shoes or
whatever it was right that's a little
less true today in 2023 I think there
are more big corporations that are
comfortable with somewhat more sort of
politically charged uh marketing
advertising uh salience to their
products but even still I I I I think
that the the like the loss of
advertisers there has had
um the loss of advertisers as an
influence on content has changed the
content
um right and the shift uh from you know
from an ad supported model where the
goal was to have a fat Sunday paper
filled with expensive colored circulars
for your local grocery store and
furniture store and electronics store I
love the uh the Circuit City ads when I
was a kid like just poured through them
for like the latest the latest in like
receiver and television technology and
like moving away from that the the loss
of Circuit City ads has changed what
kind of content papers and magazines are
willing to run I think that's not true
for a publication like reason just
because our our Revenue model right our
is is very different but it's certainly
true for the New York Times it's
certainly true for the remaining sort of
mid-sized Market papers it's certainly
true I think for you know any of the
kind of they're they're the news weekly
business is no longer what it once was
but magazines and and Publications that
fill that space and so there simply has
been a shift in it has been a response
to incentives
I think that one underappreciated change
in the subscription model is that the
old subscription model
um uh which yes was like subsidizing the
ad uh thing more than anything else but
it was an eat your Wheaties model
especially if you're a large
institutional place like I have to
subscribe to the Los Angeles Times to
know what's going on to get those juicy
Circuit City ads
um uh you know it's my civic duty to
subscribe Third Rate Henry Kissinger
op-eds that have been turned down by
bigger papers
yep right uh no and I have to subscribe
to the Wall Street Journal to know
what's going on with business if I'm if
I'm working in finance and Wall Street
you just have to subscribe to this and
that still works a little bit for
specialized places like the Wall Street
Journal maybe the economist but a lot
less so probably than before
um you know you just sort of this is
part of your civic duty is to do that
well that uh subscription model has
really really withered what has
supplanted it is an affinity based
subscription model I'm going to use my
subscriptions as a consumption to
express my affection for reason I mean
we have a webathon every year that
certainly brings in more money than it
did 12 years ago
um and uh and you know a lot of our
readers and I I can speak confidently
for Catherine and Nick on this part of
the greatest thing about being an editor
of reason is that you meet people who
have these long relationships that are
older than many of us are almost uh uh
to the institution and they care about
it and so this is an expression of their
affection and this is very true of uh of
suderman on sub stack it's very true of
other people too
um that's interesting and good if there
is the
um the the problems uh or the potential
threats of audience capture and then
there is you know people always fret
about the silosization but I think one
of the great uh disastrous
reactions to the Modern Age by those
Legacy institutions is on one hand they
looked at these formerly 25 profit
margins that they could see we're not
going to last and they said okay what
can we do here
um on the business side they're like
let's cut everything as much as possible
and squeeze the last Blood Out Of The
Stone and they cut really stupidly they
did on the Personnel side they had
buyouts which just allowed the best
people to walk out the door back when
that that was still a thing
um and they cut coverage in such a way
where you didn't you know even if they
eat your Wheaties people like there
wasn't enough Wheaties here like the LA
time sports section is like six pages
now instead of this wonderful thing that
it used to be this is really kind of no
use to it um they did that and then on
the uh now what Peter was talking about
the sort of the anti-both sciences and
movement a lot of increasingly the uh
journalistic uh Personnel establishment
um are treating their institutions as
these important places that they need to
protect the platform they're bringing
more ideology into the place and kind of
policing that ideology thinking that is
the value add here or at least that's
the thing that they that they value the
most about it personally I think that's
going to be uh disastrous because the
thing that they had an advantage of over
everybody else is that they had Deep
Pockets and they could do and they had a
history of reporting
um and at least some kind of uh idea
that they would approach things with a
certain amount of fairness and when that
goes away then there's really no there's
what are we doing here anymore it's it's
really becomes more of an ideological
organ and a lot of the the things that
we've seen over the last few years the
New York Times especially but at other
institutions NPR comes to mind
um uh the project Veritas uh project
Veritas the dancing uh all comes from
that okay that's enough blather about
that uh but thank you for the uh
question let's go to a lightning round I
wanted to get to this because it sort of
has to do with everything that we have
talked about thus far but really needs
to be lightning over the weekend uh the
former and would-be future president Don
J Trump
released a kind of amazing video uh
saying that in 2024 he wants to build
new cities on currently undeveloped
federal land in which there will be
flying cars baby subsidies and really
nice architecture Catherine
surely you cannot be opposed to flying
cars 2024. yeah it's I guess this is
Donald Trump's answer to the abundance
agenda like I guess that's where we are
and I'm pro-flying car I'm anti-subsidy
so you can see the bind that I am in
here because I am sure that none well
first of all I'm sure that this is
what we see is what there is right like
the details of this plan are like maybe
one millimeter deeper than this video
um but uh
it's it's odd right because on the one
hand what a delight to see a politician
be like hey maybe we should we should
let people try stuff maybe we should
um you know let people build stuff like
I love to hear it but then you get you
know 0.5 beautification campaign get rid
of ugly buildings right and that's like
no
not bad I want Tucker Carlson to be on
that uh commitment for sure I do
recommend to
um reason Roundtable listeners if you
are not familiar with just like the
general CJ sirimella rage about
traditionalist conservatives having
architecture opinions like go seek that
out I don't actually even know if he's
ever done a full-length treatment for us
and he should but he tweets about it on
the regular it just kind of creeps in in
his General presence so look for it
because
even though I started out as a little
baby objectivist Iran Rand gal
architecture should not be political it
is not political it doesn't make any
sense to be like I am a conservative
therefore I like
exposed beams like please stop so Nick
uh do I hear you volunteering to be
Trump's press secretary on the uh I
would I I would vote for Trump if this
was his campaign and especially if he
said like and I'll give you the land but
no other subsidies but yeah this is
[__] great are you kidding like and
it is it's Peak Boomer dementia too
because what he is basically you know
channeling is like Popular Mechanics or
boys life circuit 1969.
um and uh but you know I like already
that's better than anything Joe Biden's
talking about you know Joe Biden is
zipping around in a Corvette Donald
Trump is talking about flying over some
bizarre City uh on the Prairie somewhere
and not it's not even clear has Donald
Trump ever been to any state other than
like New York New Jersey and Florida so
he has no idea what country he's in but
yeah more power to it I love this kind
of stuff and you could see how a
Libertarian candidate somebody like Gary
Johnson you know could have pulled this
off with much more verb Verve and uh
knowledge of what it's like to live in a
in a state that is completely owned by
the federal government you said Gary
Johnson and Verve in the same sentence
Peter uh do you want to give us a
reality I just hope the flying cars are
EVS
that could be subsidized yeah to create
good manufacturing jobs
I you know if electric cars are
subsidized flying cars are going to be
super subsidized
um I uh think that the best part about
of all of this is the idea of
deregulating federal lands it's a thing
that people just really don't appreciate
much as much as they should of how much
the federal government owns and controls
land especially in the Mountain West and
the West in general military in
particular but obviously the Bureau of
Land Management and yeah open open that
up don't open the libel laws open up the
other BLM
yes exactly
um uh all right let's get to our end of
podcast what we have all been consuming
uh Nick let's start with you
uh so I watch the uh uh Chris Rock uh
Netflix special outrage selective
outrage sometimes it's called and uh
it's very good I actually happen to see
him on the tour that this was taken from
uh playing Radio City Music Hall where
he was workshopping some of this the the
main Taping that he's done is from
Baltimore and it even includes a kind of
obvious mistake that he made that he
corrects in real time but I highly
recommend it uh Chris Rock This is a it
it's taken from a longer kind of uh set
of material it's very good and it opens
with a really great defense of free
speech where I've seen this being
circulated widely
um you know he says anybody that has
anybody who thinks that words hurt has
never been punched in the face
and it's a pretty good line and it goes
from there it's it's good stuff uh it is
also the amount of uh kind of ire he
spills towards uh Will Smith and Jada
Pinkett Smith which is extended from
what I saw him live in concert is really
good it's if you're into you know if you
liked Betty Davis and Joan Crawford
feuding uh this is way way up there and
on black Twitter it is uh you know it is
on fire uh Chris Rock is seen as a black
comic that white people like and they
are backing uh Will and Jada on this but
it's good stuff highly recommended uh
the I'll just add that the two clips
that I've watched the Robert Kardashian
stuff and then the Will and Jada uh
thing the my biggest takeaway was my God
he's he really is turning into Gilbert
Gottfried like he's just hunched over
his eyes are getting even squintier it's
just yellow what all the time like that
um uh Catherine what have you been
consuming so I've been on a little
campaign to watch key episodes in shows
that I am apparently never going to get
around to so that I can be more
culturally literate and nice a
recommendation from the reason
roundtables own Ian Kaiser our faithful
um audio producer is uh in Deep Space
Nine I watched the episode treachery
faith and the Great River which is
basically Star Trek does eye pencil and
it's fantastic I can't recommend it
enough I didn't know who any of the
people in this episode were I didn't
know what was going on in the background
and it did not matter at all there is a
plot that involves basically an
elaborate series of barters done in a
limited time in order to get a crucial
repair for the ship done and a whole
interesting plot about what it means to
blow believe in God's and if you think
they walk among you how that influences
your behavior it was good y'all and I am
officially taking recommendations for
other again random Standalone episodes
that I can watch to kind of get some of
the Vibes of a show and also like extra
points if it's some kind of great little
libertarian takeaway um I did this with
the darmok episode also of Star Trek to
help me understand how that episode
correctly predicted memes like as a form
of communication and
um the Vincent van Gogh episode in
Doctor Who so if you have other thoughts
I'm open to them but uh treachery faith
in the Great River you can buy it for
like a dollar on Amazon and just watch
it and you should
uh my recommendation Catherine is to
watch the finale of Breaking Bad that
was a great way to consume the show for
me yeah the last two episodes really
last two exactly that's that's correct
um the penultimate as well and also
don't watch in case you think that it
was so great the first time around that
it's going to survive watching again and
this is probably before you were born
but Nick will remember it uh the uh the
Moonlighting episode where they do
Taming of the Shrew or some Shakespeare
thing not good didn't hold up there
there was also a whole sub-genre of
shows in the late 80s and early 90s
where the characters would somehow be
cast back into a Uso show during World
War II
that's my yeah I want this the only
thing that would have been great is if
Mash had done that or China Beach uh so
it's like you get into an even worse War
but China Beach deep cut uh all right
well Tom Sizemore pour one out yeah pour
out a big fat line of coke and maybe
heroin
surprisingly what a surprise yeah so the
first episode of season three so so you
have nothing well that's kind of what I
want to talk about so it's Star Wars and
it's fun if you like Star Wars right
um it's kind of it's you know a sort of
boba fett-esque spin-off it's not Bob
sorry Boba Fett I always want to say
Baba and that's like and it just is I'm
gonna get that right someday right so
Boba Fett I think is the guru the Pete
town for a while that's right but I
think it's even more fun if you like
modern Star Wars because the Mandalorian
which was created by Jon Favreau is
really the product of the last 15 years
or so of Star Wars stories overseen by
Dave filoni who is a top level producer
here and is written and directed
episodes and filoni stories have mostly
come in cartoon form uh starting with
the Clone Wars series then Star Wars
Rebels currently the bad batch which is
a kind of great show about a group of
Clone Troopers who rebel against the
empire right they they're like even
though they're clones they find their
individuality right and and the thing
about Dave filoni is he is a Star Wars
Super Fan and
one but still a fan and so this plays
like sort of fan fiction in that his
project is basically to rescue modern
Star Wars especially the prequels from
the stilted weirdness of George Lucas
and in the course of doing so he's more
or less built an entirely new Star Wars
mythology with weird stuff like the dark
saber and the different clans of
Mandalore which like you don't need to
really understand anything about and yet
this season is gonna Deliver us a whole
history of like the the infighting and
clans amongst the clans of of Mandalore
and how the planet got like blown up and
all that stuff
um and what it really amounts to is a
wholesale gut job of the franchise while
leaving the facade in place and so if
you walk around DC you will see all of
these row houses where like the front
wall is the same but they've literally
in some cases not just taken out all of
the Interior down to the studs they've
also taken out the back wall of the roof
and like there's no real house left it's
just the front wall but it still sort of
fits in you're like oh it's that house
I've walked by play this a million times
that's Star Wars today under Dave filoni
he's just built a whole new mythological
infrastructure out of what George Lucas
created and in a lot of ways that's to
George Lucas's credit because George
Lucas has always said well look you know
this is a this is in some sense a group
project even you know in the starting in
the late 1980s or so he allowed the
expanded universe to come in to you know
to be built out uh which has now been
sort of omitted from the Canon but he
allowed the creation of a whole sort of
Universe of extra stories he allowed
fans to make uh to make things like the
great mockumentary mashup of cops and
Star Wars troops which was one of the
first fan made
um uh movies to sort of go viral on the
internet in the late 1990s and George
Lucas had always sort of had this LAX
attitude towards his work where yeah you
know what if you're gonna profit off of
it then it needs to come through me but
I will let you tell stories in this
world and if you're not gonna profit off
of it you know go Bonkers go bananas I
feel like that actually is just gonna
like make people even happier with it
it's going to make people love Star Wars
more the fact that they get to play
around in this and so filoni I think
combines those Tendencies he is a fan
and treating this in many ways like a
fan although he's doing this of course
under the official auspices of lucasfilm
and
it's just been fascinating to watch the
evolution of the series basically over
the course of my entire life and I think
the Mandalorian it's it's not I don't
know it's not great but it's really fun
it's expertly delivered the effects work
is actually better than a lot of movies
that I've been seeing recently
um if you like Star Wars if you like
modern Star Wars if you like Star Wars
cartoons the Mandalorian season 3 now in
Disney plus it's pretty good it's
enjoyable
it's uh baby Yoda toiletrained yet I I
think he's still working on not eating
the uh they're like infant fetuses of
the um the Frog lady
it's hard for him
I also before we get off Star Wars
now we haven't spent enough time on Star
Wars but um a couple of years ago I
suggested that jar jar was a Senator uh
in the Star Wars universe and in fact he
wasn't he was merely a representative of
you know wherever the suck he's from
yeah of like a denim clad future in
which the uh survivors wait is jar jar
like is he like it is an Eleanor Holmes
Norton situation I think he's like the
Eleanor Holmes Norton and that is so
racist Catherine I don't even want to
wow acknowledge it again no but it's
actually I think it's queen or pre-queen
amidula or you know amygdala is the
actual Senator
uh all right this is the section
actually it's Kevin it's Kevin Kramer
Kevin Kramer is the senator from Nauvoo
this is the section of the podcast where
Nick stops talking
yeah Nick stop talking I'm the problem
here uh
good point my uh my cultural
recommendation uh is speaking of boys
life 1969 in cartoons it's Apollo 10 and
a half which is a cartoon about a boy in
1969. literally uh boy uh this is
Richard linklater he does the same kind
of Animation that they did he did in a
scanner darkly so it's they filmed a
live action against a green screen and
then did the weird thing on it
afterwards rotoscoping thank you for the
word
um and uh it was introduced to me by my
eight-year-old daughter she's like Hey
Dad I think you'll like this one uh and
I was really kind of wonderful to watch
her watch it with me because it is a
anyone who grew up in the 1970s to any
degree
um will have at least some uh affinity
for it because it's largely it's a
magical realist tale about a 10 year old
kid who um who grows up in Houston and
dad works for NASA because everyone's
dad works for NASA and they're in the
new suburb
um and the the magical part of the
magical realism Fable is that he as the
10 year old has a secret mission that
predates the the man uh Landing uh on
Mars because they built a spacecraft too
small I'm not giving it away uh and they
had to put a kid in it but the
the uh the realism part is the rest of
the movie which is just basically this
is what life was like as a kid growing
up uh in 69 but it's very 70s like
here's the cereals here's the TV shows
here's the kind of stuff that we would
play here's the the back of the pickup
truck that we would all sit on the edge
of as we're flying down the highway and
no one cared this is the station wagon I
mean just so many things that are name
checked
um uh anyone who I know who has seen it
who's roughly my age uh just lists off
all the things that they've they've uh
recognized and identify with and then if
you grew up as I did in uh in a very uh
Aerospace kind of uh region it's just
it's nuts how much it hits almost the
point where it's like it could be too
much for people who are allergic to
here's just all the way the culture was
consumed
um back then but it was an interesting
way to transmit the uh Hey
eight-year-old here's how my childhood
was and then she had the great idea like
let's watch it with Grandma and Grandpa
so watch with my mom and my stepdad the
next night after watching it was really
kind of a fun experience I really really
like it
um it it's kind of it pairs well with a
recent essay by Freddie de Boer and
that's not a phrase that I use often in
a recommendation uh uh a thing where he
talks about uh uh life in the 90s and
how it was different to be like a
teenager in the 90s
um than it is now just sort of like
listing the almost banal types of ways
but it is really interesting how
different the acquisition of culture was
uh from the 70s to the 90s to the odds
and the final thing I'll add to this or
whatever we're living through the 20s
the the new Roaring 20s
um I also had the the privilege of of
watching this and thinking about these
kind of different things with uh my mom
is writing it working on her Memoir
right now and talks about her uh
upbringing in the 1940s and uh the way
that they kind of acquired culture and
dealt with stuff just really like a kind
of a wonderful mashup to see all of this
and it's really hard to escape the
conclusion that again my eight-year-old
has like wow just so much better now
isn't that great though I mean that's
that's a great message that should be
shattered from the rooftop it really is
it actually really is
um uh even though she enjoyed uh the
movie and enjoyed uh imagining what it'd
be like to like watch Twilight Zone in
um uh she's very uh excited that she
lives in the as someone who grew up in
the 1990s in a government engineer
culture there were a lot of uh uh air
force uh rocket scientists where I grew
up
and uh there were contractors for the
most part but um a lot of a lot of
Rocket scientists and like I there were
there were some similarities but I'll
just say like you don't have to be
exactly Matt's age to have enjoyed that
movie it's really just delightful and it
does it's like rockets without being
overly sentimental
were rocket scientists in the 90s like
was that a good time to be a rocket
scientist or was it kind of like uh
we're not doing I think it was a pretty
good time to be a rocket so it's just
where I lived in Rocket Science Central
yeah that's uh Matt is Alex Jones does
he have a cameo in this as he does in
most Richard Linkletter movies not that
I'm aware not that I'm aware of uh via
the main narration voice which I only
saw in the uh in the credits was a Jack
Black and he's terrific um just so it
has this really nice mild kind of Austin
or not Austin but uh Houston uh draw
it's great
um all right uh we're running late
thanks for listening uh if you like our
stuff in the Affinity subscription model
um go to reason.com donate um or
subscribe to the damn magazine it's
pretty good it's cheap too go for it uh
and uh also if you like our podcast go
to reason.com podcast to get the recent
interview with nicholaspy and also the
Soho forum debate series with Dr Gene
Epstein uh Nick do you have any speakers
business coming can I just point out two
things one I was an eagle scat mat so I
didn't read Boys Life in 1969 but I was
subscribing to it a decade later and
Gene Epstein only has a masters he's not
a doctor he's not part of the
professoriator or the doctorate have you
not seen the man dance
that is a Chinese plot I think but in
any case uh we've got a great uh version
of our live stream with vinay Prasad uh
coming up on Wednesday and on Monday
April 3rd in New York City we're gonna
have the authors of the individualist
John tomasi and Matt swollinski uh doing
a live interview uh in Midtown Manhattan
go to reason.com events and you'll be
able to get information about that later
today
awesome all right thanks see you next
week
[Music]